[Applaudissements]
est ce que paris va enfin avoir son
équipe professionnelle mais il est
d'accord pour la création d'une grande
équipe de football à paris oui ouais
pourquoi parce que ça manque
le paris saint germain à gauche en
maillot sombre était au complet cet
après midi pour son premier match
officiel donc vous gardez votre écusson
de paris saint germain si je comprends
bien et il y aura un club professionnel
qui sera le paris football club majorité
des deux tiers six envie c'est pour moi
c'est l'image d'une anomalie française
dans un français de joker après lyon
après marseille revenait avec le paris
saint germain football john edwards 6
années on a quand même pas finir
champions mais pourquoi pas ceci est à
peu près certain que les sera des nôtres
au mois de mai prochain
ce qu'on appelle une vraie histoire
d'hommes comme dans un film
oh